now for the costume design Awards I have
to go backstage to see if the pretty
actresses who will model the costumes
are ready I know I am while I'm going I
leave you in the capable hands of the
handsome Fernando Lamas and his lovely
Arlene doll
in motion pictures the classic function
of the costume designer is to buy
clothing that furthers of story
its theme and its mood and health actors
better realize the characters they
portray this year because of the wide
variety of stories selected for the big
screen our costume designers faced an
even greater challenge to authenticity
than ever before this then is not a
fashion show but a parade of the
brilliant achievements of our industry's
costume designers the nominees for the
Academy Awards the nominees for the
black and white tunic costume design are
ITA's head for Korea the costume is
warned by Miss Barbara Larson
Rozlyn air and many wills for the Diary
of Anne Frank costume is worn by Miss
Julie pain Ellen Rose for the gazebo
past whom is worn by Miss Tibet Vimeo
Laura Kelly for some like it hot bottom
is warm and easy DeRozan
Howard shoot for the young Philadelphia
master was worn by this dynamic pain
the winner is some like it hot
beautiful I thank you
and particularly Tony Curtis and Jack
Lemmon as the world would say they never
look lovelier
the nominees for color costume design
are Elizabeth happened then for burn her
costume is worn by Miss Cindy wood
Adela Palmer or the best of everything
costume is worn by this Linda watches
Rene for the big fisherman costume is
worn by Miss Nancy Walters
even here for the five pennies pasta was
worn by mr. Stephens
Irene shut up for poor Gambas costume is
worn by miss Isabel cooling the winner
is Elizabeth happened then burn her
behalf of mr. Hammond and I would like
to say thank you